you mentioned in popular discourse
um
a kind of a distorted use of different
terms and one of them is marxism yeah
today is there something you just speak
to about
you know increased
use of that word and is it misused does
it concern you that there's a lot of
actually young people that say they're
sort of proudly marxist
are they misusing the term they are
definitely misusing the term if they
don't understand
the use value exchange value dialectic i
went through earlier uh so so if i don't
if i just pause the idea of socialism
and marxism is used in sort of popular
lingo yeah it's basically
you know um a lot of people have a
disproportionately hard life
why can't we help them out
why can't we be kind to our fellow man
kind of that's that's
a short embodiment of an idea as opposed
to some
super complicated uh elaborate
model of the economy and politics
i mean we could do that by using the
insights that come out of modern
monetary theory which i've confirmed
just using my simple minsky models and
that is that to use the term usually a
feature not a bug
a government running a deficit is the
feature
of a well-functioning
mixed fiat credit economy not a bug the
government should normally run a deficit
because that's how the government
creates money now because we've had this
obsession from mainstream economists
running a surplus which is what caused
the great depression calvin cool is
doing it for eight years because of that
obsession we've cut back on social
services we've cut back on health we've
cut back on education we've cut back on
infrastructure now all that stuff
predominantly affects the poor because
the rich can afford to buy it themselves
so if we had a son which realizes the
government should run a deficit it's a
feature not a bug of a fiat money system
and that's where eons made one mistake
recently okay we're not going back to
first principles that deficit
enables you to provide an enough
of a decent standard of living for those
who don't come out on top in the
the capitalist game
and with that you wouldn't have the
angst of the young people now we still
have the climate
parameters within which we have to
survive but a decent level of government
funding would mean the yanks that you
get where people say i want to be a
marxist
and they've got a what i call a
cardboard cutout version of marks in
their minds that wouldn't be happening
so it's it's potential to have a
good society where the government runs a
deficit that finances
the the needs of the poor where the rich
get enough to you know indulge and take
care of themselves
and you you don't get this breakdown if
you if you try to cause the government
running a surplus then the burden of
that is borne by the poor
middle class and poor and that will lead
to the angst we're now seeing
you